do women have an intolerance of sexy
peers
absolutely um
100% uh I we say we don't we say that we
just love women and we promote women but
um we look we love certain women and we
promote certain women so uh yeah we're
we're not the angels that we purport we
are to be um I think we do a lot of
impression
management who are the women the we do
support and love um it depends like
obviously we're going to have um
different qualities that we admire in a
person and so if they have those then I
think that that's who we're going to
promote we're pretty good at um
tolerating our friends and promoting our
friends um but I don't think we're
universally kind to all women and it's
interesting because I think that there's
been this like change in zist where
people where women talk about how The
Sisterhood has never been stronger and
we support each other unconditionally
and yet we really
don't why why why do you think that
that's the current pop
culture summarization of female
friendships uh and why is it not the
case well I think that it it's funny
because it's kind of said but it's not
really said so have you seen the Barbie
movie yet no okay you need to see it
it's really good okay but anyhow so it's
funny because there's this big speech
where she talks about like all the
pressures that women are under and
everything that we have to manage and
you know and then there's also this like
Thread about women supporting women and
yet there's like plenty of examples of
women not supporting women in that movie
right so I think that there's this like
a little bit of a disconnect where we
say it but then we don't actually um
live that ideal um now the reason I
think it happens that we don't support
each other as much as we should is
because there's like a resource security
that affects women I think more than men
and I or this perception of resource
scurity and in some places in the world
there's absolutely resource scurity um
with women you know they're not they
don't have as many privileges they don't
make as much money those sorts of things
um and when things don't seem fair it's
hard to be uh
generous right so what's the sexy bit of
the sexy peers why be particularly
intolerant of the sexy ones so so that
would be um the idea
that it's GNA sound
sexist but it's a robust finding I did a
study on this so the idea that um
historically we've sort of
maintained uh control over what the
opposite sex wanted and so if we um you
know are giving away sex freely you mean
we as women we as women then then we
don't hold that we don't the power of
that resource is um is less it's even
non-existent so it would behoove us to
then punish those who give away sex too
freely so shame um debase women who
are a threat to that power holding
position
and so this is a study that I did that
showed that exact phenomenon it has
since been replicated around the world
and basically um women are intolerant of
certain types of women but in
particularly they're particularly
intolerant of women who are
sexy and it's a universal
phenomenon right so it's sexy is a very
specific word to use here this isn't
necessarily just attractive I it's like
presumably sexually provocative
exactly it's not attractive per se
although I think that if you get to the
end of that Spectrum on attractiveness
so like you're incredibly attractive I
think that that would publicly unnerve
some women because that person would be
um would be revered by men and that
would then debase their own standing in
terms ter of competition but generally
speaking I mean yeah
so the the impression would be that
you're sexually provocative or available
what was the study that you did or are
there any that came along after yours
and did it even better that you prefer
well I don't know if anybody's done it
better because I think I did it the best
but because I thought about it forever
and ever it took like over a decade to
for the study to come to fruition so
basically what I saw all the time was
that when a woman violated Norms so the
norm of you know you could be sexy but
not too sexy um then women would mock
them they would use indirect aggression
an indirect aggression um takes the form
of gossiping peer group exclusion um but
also more non-verbal things like you
know the once over where you start at
the top you look down you look up but
you don't smile to convey disgust or you
stare at each other and then when she
leaves the room you laugh those sorts of
things so anyhow I saw that over and
over again so I um designed a study with
my post-doctoral student anel Sharma
where we had women come into the lab
they were part of this previous study
where we were looking at their use of
indirect aggression then we invited them
into the lab to talk about female
friendships how they deal with conflict
um we randomized them into one of four
conditions with their friend with a
stranger and whether or not they were
going to be interrupted in their
conversation by a very sexy dress
Confederate or a conservatively dressed
Confederate and the person was the exact
it was the same person Lisa gorgeous
absolutely
gorgeous anyhow we standardized
everything right down to the number of
steps she took everything was scripted
so they came through they didn't know
that we were recording them right from
the get-go she came through and walked
right between the two women
and mentioned to entel in the back room
that I needed to talk to her about
something and then she left with anel
and we recorded what they did and
everybody in the sexy condition treated
her poorly with two exceptions um and I
think they were just not paying
attention because had had they be been
they would have done something and those
that when um Lisa interrupted them and
she was just dressed conservatively they
didn't even pay attention so the only
thing that was different between the two
conditions was her sexy
outfit wow okay so what are the
implications of this what does it what
does it tell you about female psychology
it tells us that like I mean a lot of
times people think that the suppression
of women's sexuality is done by men and
it is done by men um for sure that
exists and especially in certain
countries but it also is policed by
women and women do suppress other
women's sexual
expression so on average would you say
more shaming comes from men or from
women I think it depends on the country
it really does there's a cultural
component to that but let's just talk
about Western cultures um I think that
uh that women are particularly
intolerant of sexy peers more so than
men does it bother you to see a sexy
woman me no but I I would campaign for
more if there was
OPP and would would you be upset if
women were more promiscuous yeah
precisely I mean this this is from Roy
bow Meister I learned this from him that
he was saying it it's very strange to
lay at the feet of men a restriction in
female sexual Freedom given the fact
that almost every man if given the
opportunity would campaign for that
precise thing like exactly I I haven't
been to a parade downtown here in Austin
but if there was one for that you know
that would be up there with one of the
you know for for my other male Brethren
I'm going to stand firm and I will help
I you know you will you will finally be
able to get your endway so yeah I I I it
makes complete sense to me and I learned
from Jeffrey Miller and tuer Max as well
this insight about the game theory of
shaming
where if you think about sex as having a
price and if one woman is prepared to
lower the price from three dates to one
date or from x amount of resources to
0.5 x amount of resources that lowers
the market value of whatever that thing
is overall so you exactly that's exactly
what I showed y you need you need a
price enforcement mechanism it's a
cartel yeah and that's and bound M's
theory that so he wrote a paper with
Jean twiy where they talk about this and
this is what I used as the theoretical
basis for the study along with what I
knew about uh indirect aggression so
it's interesting because uh interest
sexual competition is like one area that
people study but indirect aggression is
very similar it's like the behavior the
manifestation of inter seexual
competition it's the enforcement
mechanism of interex competition and
people hadn't really considered that so
I wrote a theory it was published in
trans be of the royal Royal Society and
it did very well and um people have used
it now to springboard other studies but
basically I was arguing just that that
the form of intersexual competition the
form of takes in women is indirect
aggression interesting I've got a quote
from you here sex is Coveted by men
accordingly women limit access as a way
of maintaining advantage in the
negotiation of this resource women who
make sex too readily available
compromise the power holding position of
the group which is why many women are
particularly intolerant of women who are
or seem to be promiscuous and it's the
seem toe bit I think which is
particularly interesting there exactly
it's interesting because after that
study came out was in Florida at Disney
with my daughter who was eight and I we
brought along her two girlfriends and
there was a woman who was dressed um in
a very sexually provocative manner she
was probably in her mid-50s uh tiny tiny
skirt tiny tiny shirt Florida baby out
Florida look gorgeous look gorgeous
anyhow and uh I turned around and I saw
these three eight-year-olds doing
exactly what was done in my study so so
she was getting she was getting the once
over by three mean eight-year-olds well
what I mean that's fascinating what why
would it be the case
that animals who aren't even sexually
active who don't understand what sex is
How Deeply wired is this at the base of
the brain stem that even they have got
an idea she might be too promiscuous and
maybe she's going to take some future
husband away from me I don't know if
it's at the brain stem but it's
certainly there's like a lot of
socialization around this think about um
school dress codes so we've had tons of
pressure in Canada a lot of schools have
had to revoke their school dress codes
because they're sexist where they punish
girls for dressing um in small clothes
but not boys and so they've gotten rid
of them and under that the premise that
it is sexist which it is hang but anyhow
hang
on a boy do boys want to wear small
clothes well they wear tank tops I think
that's a small clothing right okay so
girls and girls are allowed to wear
things like skirts and vests so we don't
typically wear um so we don't wear
uniforms in North American schools
unless you go to a private school okay
but my point is is that these um dress
codes exist and they've long existed and
just now in 2023 are we getting rid of
them and um little girls know about them
and little boys know about them and they
know about why they know that they're
unfair or they feel that they're unfair
they are unfair um so where does that
come from so it's like really hard to
separate um The evolutionary
significance of this from the the
massive socialization pressure that
they're under so I do think that it's
rooted in our evolutionary history I
wrote that in a in a paper that two 2013
paper I talked about that theoretical
paper um I do think that there's an
evolutionary significance to our
Behavior but I also think that um you
know we're Society in general across the
world um is quite intolerant of this why
is it the case if this is true and I
believe that it's true and I've been
singing this game theory of shaming
song for at least a few years now why is
it the case that we are a Sisterhood
that is all together these men need to
stop controlling our sexuality it's all
girl power stuff how is that
meme remaining so sticky if the truth
doesn't seem to actually match up to the
that sort of zeitgeist I think it's easy
for us to blame you and not look at
ourselves right and I do think that
there's truth that some sometimes it
does exist like we talked about like do
you get upset by somebody dressing sexy
absolutely not but some men do for sure
and in some cultural groups they really
do right um we know that that's the case
um but that said I just think that and
this is the book that I have coming out
next year called mean with Simon and
Shuster and it's basically just that
trying to reconcile that so you know a
good feminist doesn't say what I'm
saying so um a good feminist supports
women no matter what and yet a good
feminist actually doesn't support all
women like if you really look at the
behavior of women you see that um you
know we say that it's men oppressing
women but it's also women oppressing
women and if we can acknowledge that uh
we can manage it indirect competition do
men use that too what's the what's the
ratio of indirect competition between
the Sexes So proportionally speaking and
I'll talk about indirect aggression
because indirect um competition I'm not
too sure what that means per se so
indirect aggression um is used by men
for sure men talk about each other they
gossip they give each other the silent
treatment that sort of thing but not as
often so men use a mange of behaviors so
you guys are like straight out in your
face um you uh are physically aggressive
and you also use indirect aggression uh
indirectly aggressive tactics whereas
women proportionately speaking only use
this form of aggression of course there
are exceptions there's some women are
really violent but they are rare and
they're so Salient when we see these
women they make the front page of every
news Outlet in the world because we
don't see them that often so this is our
exclusive way of dealing with each other
when we're um being less than
appropriate being less than kind
interesting okay so and we're more
affected by it so if I rolled my eyes at
you it it's not gonna cause much
distress if I did that to a woman it
would cause some problems and there's
quite a bit of study showing that we
have a heightened physiological response
to being um ostracized rejected um all
of the things that Encompass indirect
aggression so women are more attuned to
more attuned to it and we res respond to
it more and that has an evolutionary
significance because belonging was far
more important to women than to men not
to suggest that you didn't need to
belong you needed to get your coalitions
set right so that you could win the war
and kill the boore
but um for women we also needed um Alo
parents we needed support from other
women and so it's a really interesting
um issue because on the one hand you
need the support of women but in another
hand there's not enough resources to go
around so there's also a zero sum game
in a sense attached to that so it's
trying to reconcile that so then the way
to do it then is to be strategic is to
um appear to be on your side but not
really be on your
side why is it so important to not be
directly aggressive as a woman so um
Anne Campbell wrote this really great
theory about this and basically it was
about she called it staying alive and so
if women
historically um got into a physical
battle a fight and they died or were
injured and not able to take care of
their off off Spring those Offspring did
not survive so historically and in some
places in the world it still exists um
infant survival is inextricably um
linked to maternal survival so we can't
be fighting all over the place I think
it's not good for our health and
wellness and it's certainly not good for
our Offspring so how do you get your
genes into the Next Generation they got
to grow up and make babies and cells
okay whereas if the man was to die in
some fist fight gone wrong the kids are
still probably going to survive mom's
still around men also a little bit more
physically robust bit more tolerant of
being HIIT in the head that's why you've
got the brow Ridge and the bigger hands
and blah blah blah okay how how
effective is indirect aggression and
just before we say that to get to that
um before I answer that the other thing
too is that men don't always stick
around and yet we still we still have
managed it'd be better if they did
historically they haven't always though
and they still don't really always stick
around I just needed to put that dig in
okay see because I'm like really good at
indirect aggression from that research
it is effective it is effective it I
felt it in my soul what is that me
search research so um it's incredibly
effective it really is and again because
women are so attuned to it so it doesn't
have the same hit on men so us using it
against men doesn't have the same effect
but man are we ever good at picking it
up women we see it in a nanc I coach
adolescent girls I'm a high performance
soccer coach and I tell them I can hear
them roll their eyes like a kilometer
away I know when it's going down and we
do we we notice that um there are memes
like you go on to any social media
platform and there's tons of memes of
like you know a woman like opening the
door real quickly because she heard
somebody like roll their eyes or do a
you know we come back in we hear it we
know it there's a number of interesting
studies going on at the moment to do
with female sports I think um tennis
players and basketball players on
opposite teams given that you've been
doing your ethnographic uh in place
research with your high performance
female soccer team what have you
observed about inter in team love and
distaste and all that stuff oh noticed
so much and in fact I've studied a lot
of the things that I've noticed so one
of the things I've noticed and then we
actually have a study that showed this
to be true more so for adolescent girls
than for adolescent boys but adolescent
girls make a lot of social comparisons
is she prettier than me is she better
than me if she's smarter than me is she
more popular those social comparisons
elicit jealousy and the way that
jealousy is managed is either it's
turned inward they become depressed
anxious the like I'm not as good as so
and so or they turn it outward which is
more common and they tear down their
rival so the only reason that she's
playing Left fullback and I'm a left
fullback is because her dad's the coach
or her mom's the coach that sort of
thing so we show we showed that
longitudinally that's the pathway and we
showed it to be stronger in girls than
in boys one thing I notice all the time
is that um like when somebody's done you
wrong on the field you can't let Let It
Go if you're a girl or a woman but men
just go out for a beer right after the
game they don't give a it's done
with let's move on right does that
matter whether it's your own team or the
opposition we can't let it go from the
opposition so I'll get to this so what
happens is um it's very common to do a
handshake after the game in North
America and um and for you to not get
your hand shook by somebody who thinks
you did them dirty on the field whereas
man just shake hands and get on with it
and there was a study that looked at
this across I think it was 44 different
countries post affiliative Behavior
after competitions and it showed that
women around the world just can't let it
go so like if somebody's done us wrong
it's there it's there for life like if
you did me wrong in grade five and I ran
into you just now it's on okay so anyhow
so I noticed that and I don't notice and
I've coached little boys too and I've
never noticed that and then they talk
about the girls on the other team and
the women on the other team and what a
I can't believe she did this this
and that like they are personally
offended by a slide tackle gone wrong
whereas you know men don't don't really
seem to care about that and then the
other thing I've noticed that is that on
a girl's team or a young women's team
the best player on the team is not
necessarily the most popular player on
the team whereas in boys teams and men's
teams the best player on the team is
almost invariably always the most
popular person on that team is always
the leader so we don't care if you're
the best per se unless you get to like
the high high high end of um of elite
women's sports um that's not what makes
you popular and in fact being the best
might actually make get you bullied on a
girl's team or a women's team because
how dare you think you're so good so
there's this whole theory about tripping
the prom queen I've written about it um
knocking down the tall Poppy and we're
pretty good at making sure women stay in
their place and if they're not going to
stay in their place and they're going to
think too well of themselves we'll put
them back there real quick okay so
status and competence are split apart in
female hierarchies in a way that they
are not in male hierarchies 100% And
it's interesting because I read Carly
Lloyd's autobiography and she talked
about how Carly Lloyd is one of the most
decorated women's uh football player in
the world she won the Balon do um for
the uh and also the best player for uh
the FIFA World Cup when it was here in
Canada in 2015 she wred her in her
autobiography she talks about how when
she joined the national team that
sometimes she felt that women weren't
passing to her the ball even because she
was seen as competition and can you
imagine like you know if you're playing
a sport even if it's like a beer league
and you're not that good as a guy you
take yourself off and sit on the bench
so that you guys can win the
championship whereas I think and it's
been said by many of my colleagues in
some ways women and girls would rather
lose the game and have everybody play
than win now of course I'm not talking
about at the elite elite level because
that's going to have different
parameters and different personality
types but you've got this preference for
egalitarianism the we have preference
for knowing your place and staying in
your
place yeah I
uh I learned some interesting stuff to
do with the behavior of male and female
students as they walk out of exam halls
and they talk to each other and the guys
will say oh yeah question three
absolutely smashed it I I revised that
like that was absolutely great whereas
the girls would go oh you know I was all
really I've probably failed it's not so
good and the guys will also say that too
but it seems like the guys have less of
an issue proclaiming their successes uh
again also super interesting study where
um girls will tend to downplay
qualifications and accolades if they
think that their responses are going to
be seen by other people as opposed to if
they're being kept private so there is
this very below the surface you know
under sea current that's going on here
with how women play with status uh what
they want other people to know about
their accolades and their
accomplishments they do not want to
enact the ey or the jealousy or the Envy
of any of the other girls specifically
that are in their location and I think
the final bit is they're probably at
least partially aware that many of the
accomplishments that they could be
talking about probably don't impact
their mate value all that much so it's
going to be a detriment to me to the
females that are around me and maybe not
that like is the is the guy around you
going to be that much more attracted to
you if you say that you smashed that
exam than if you didn't like is your
socioeconomic competence going to be a
big part of it he's not going to be
turned off by it that's for sure but
what's going to happen is like the
reason why women they make themselves
smaller not because of men they make
themselves smaller so that they don't
get
they don't attract the negative
attention of women we can't brag we
can't say what we're good at because
then you think you're special and you'll
get torn down and then and then we
wonder why we lack confidence right like
it's it's just really interesting a lot
of times people will talk about how
women dress for other women and it
there's some truth to that right like we
really are trying to um please other
women and um and minimize the discomfort
that could could come um from not
pleasing them um Amy Schumer has this
really funny skit and you should try and
find it after where it's like women
basically use we use a lot of
self-deprecating humor so we put
ourselves down all the time like oh my
goodness you know if somebody says
something nice about us like are you
kidding me I just found that in the
garbage and put it on me you know like
whatever you know we go on and on and
and make sure that um we don't think
well of our ourselves or give the
impression that we think well of
ourselves so the skit goes on about
women just putting themselves down all
around and then this one woman somebody
compliments her and she just says thanks
and all of their heads explode what do
you mean thanks like we just said
something and nice about yourself you're
supposed to put yourself down those are
the rules so it it's spot on what she
did in this in this skit talk to me
about how jealousy mediates this
relationship then between uh
attractiveness comparison and indirect
aggression so it it it actually works
just like that it's it's a mediator
right so it explains the relationship so
if I am jealous then um I need to remedy
that icky feeling that's not a good
feeling and so I have a couple different
ways I could do it or more than a couple
I have a few different ways I can manage
it but the more often the more common
way it's managed is by attacking myself
or attacking the source of my comparison
the that's making me feel jealous and
women are very good at attacking um
other women whom they perceive to have
more but again they justify it so back
to remember we started off with
impression management um so they use a
variety of cognitive strategies to make
their egregious acts more palatable and
um and one way they do it is they they
make it so that the the person that's
being targeted um had it coming to them
it was justified so if she wasn't so er
arant if she wasn't um you know whatever
it is it's going to be then I wouldn't
have treated her
poorly interesting did you see and by
the way like I can predict what the
reaction's going to be when this comes
out and when my book comes out too the
reaction is going to be that um you know
I have internalized the misogyny myself
that you know so is your data apparently
pardon me so is your data apparently
yeah exactly like I I obviously don't
like women and I don't like women
because I've believed what men have said
about women um and yet you know we do
these really sneaky studies and in the
right context we see it done we it comes
out like in full force so I don't know
like maybe there is a bit of
internalized misogyny I'll own I'll own
some of the variants but a lot of this
is uh it persists because it works it's
very very effective you don't need to
worry we've had Tanya Reynolds and Joyce
benon and you know there are there are
many female heads that have been chopped
off by the internet before you've got
here I think everyone that's listening
is fully aware of the fact
that being a woman being a female and
trying to navigate the delicate Samurai
blade that is the female status
hierarchy is really really tough and it
does not get any easier it is not
made you're no more prepared by ignoring
the sort of thermodynamics of how these
interactions work it but I mean how do
you change it if you can't acknowledge
it right so like I I'm prepared I've you
know I've dealt with it for many many
years I know what's going to be said and
ironically they use indirect aggression
to make their point and I just think
like seriously you don't see the irony
and and how you're behaving because
certainly we should be tolerant of
people holding different viewpoints it's
not like I'm espousing hate speech but
um Mr Rogers of all people said that if
it's mentionable it's manageable so how
do then we change our Behavior if we
can't acknowledge it and it causes a lot
of harm like I mean we've we've kind of
been joking around here but some young
women take their lives over this some
older women take their lives over it
teenage girls take their lives over this
um you know the bullying uh that they
endure is real it's significant it's
linked to eating disorders depression
anxiety suicidality so I mean this is an
important uh worthy area of study we got
to get this right the issue that you
come up against is anything which is
seen as not being upfront very very
positive for whichever the maligned or
lower down group is is always presumed
it's always castigated very quickly as
being the thing which is at fault and
it's the child wants to eat ice cream
every night that is what the child wants
and would be enjoyable but is ultimately
not good for it in the long run so your
front-loading compassion but backloading
all of the issues that come from not
actually understanding what the problem
is in the first place exactly um I I
would love for women to be and some
women are I mean women in Academia I
find are very tough and and can handle
uh opinions being um expressed directly
and in contradiction to their own
viewpoints but I just wish just
generally speaking I think if we were a
little less um sensitive a little bit
more tolerant um a little bit more
honest then I we'd probably be in a
better position in terms of uh wielding
power holding power um progressing with
power did you see this uh hypothetical
hairdressing clients study that came out
a little while ago okay so give me one
more hint I feel like I know this uh I
explored how women sabotage hypothetical
hairdressing clients through
disingenuous Beauty advice which would
detrimentally impact clients physical
attractiveness in both studies the more
attractive the client the more hair was
recommended to be cut off both laay
women and female professional
hairdressers cut most hair off women who
are of the same attractiveness level as
them with women cutting the most hair of
women they perceive to be about as
attractive as themselves they sabotaged
women whose hair was in good condition
and had requested a smaller amount cut
off to a greater extent than women with
hair in poor condition client makeup
caused lower mate value lay women to cut
off less hair suggesting the dominance
incited by women wearing makeup resulted
in reduced sabotage more inex
competitive women including hairdressers
cut off more hair confirming competitor
manipulation as intrasexual
competitiveness strategy being employed
yes it that study finds itself in the
book
amazing um it's interesting because I
had this one um girlfriend in high
school we were in that popular group and
everybody was very attractive and had a
lot of um assets and competencies that
the peer group valued but anytime she
told me that I looked really good in an
outfit I automatically had to change
it anything she said like I mean I just
like it was almost like a that
opposite day I look like crap and this
is why she's saying it wow that is so
good and that's my reaction to all women
right but like experience tells you
what's going on Bill Burr has this
amazing bit about the PO body positivity
movement he thinks basically that the
body positivity movement is women
encouraging other women to push
themselves further and further out of
the appropriate mate value dating pool
that you know as you applaud women for
being the size that they are it makes a
really good case that well yeah you get
all of the points of being you know
morally grandstanding and I am empathy
and I care for the the the downtrodden
group and so on and so forth but you are
also doing something that benefits your
own mate uh value right which is moving
more and more women away from wherever
you are so are we that Mack of alien I
think that
the
underlying uh turbulence that happens
below the surface is so effective it
doesn't matter whether you are or
whether you aren't the net result is
what works and ultimately I think that
this would you know because that's some
sneaky that is some sneaky but
I don't think that it's I don't think
pretty much any woman is cognizant of
this I this is again it's a bit from
Bill Burr that I was listening to and as
I was listening to I was like wow this
sounds like really comprehensive
intersexual competition from women to
push the women out of of the mating pool
hm I wonder if that's so this is total
Bro Science here right and you know what
interesting because I have a reaction to
it because like here I know people are
gonna women are going to have a reaction
to everything I said and now I'm having
a reaction to this so I'm GNA have to
give this some thought because like I
want to believe that we're not that
Macky of alien and I also want to
believe that um we we I I do know we
have free will and we're consci
conscious beings and conscientious indiv
idual as well so I don't know I'm not
I'm not buying that one just yet high
hopes for Humanity okay so one of the
other things you mentioned it earlier on
about
um bullying the sort of the effect of
Youth
ostracization on especially young girls
uh some of the stuff that I learned from
your work one in four children report
that they have experienced clinically
elevated rates of depression 25% of
Children and adolescents reported that
they had experienced significant
depression incidents and H
hospitalization rates for new onset
Eating Disorders increased by 60% during
the pandemic and rates for emergency
department visits for attempted suicide
have increased by 22% in the past few
years what is going on with young
people's mental health so there's been a
general decline in their mental health
for the
past 15 years or so so it has it wasn't
good before the pandemic and it was
worse during the pandemic and it'll be
interesting to see what happens in the
next few years so I've been studying um
mental health and violence for years and
not the violence like not the mental
health of violent people but what
happens when people are exposed to
violence and the mental health issues
that ensue um so we have this crisis
this Mental Health crisis that's
particularly pronounced for adolescent
girls and young women and there's a
bunch of reasons why this could be the
case um during the pandemic I think that
a lot of it had to do with um social
isolation there's a lot of evidence to
support that the need to belong as a
fundamental human motivator to all but
it's particularly pronounced for women
and we talked about this already so
staying alive so you know belonging
being in a group affiliating all of
those things are really important for my
survival and my Offspring survival um so
I think that challenged girls and women
particularly during the pandemic
um but also too we're we're more we're
exposed to violence more than men so
we're more likely to be um victims of
intimate partner violence um you know uh
everything except for Murder Men get
murdered more than women um and then
they're uh we're big on social
comparisons and so social media has not
been really good for um adolescent girls
and for women um I think all of those
things contribute to poor mental health
well if you look at Greg lukanov and
Jonathan Height's work they lay an awful
lot of the changes at the feet of social
media what's your what's your
perspective on that do you think it is
the patient zero of all of this or is
there more going on there's going to be
more going on it'll never be you're
never going to find one thing that
causes everything um but I do think it
counts for a lot of the variants I
really do um we see this over and over
again like I don't do any clinical work
anymore but certainly this was something
that was when I worked in the mood
disorders clinic when I was doing my
internship is something I saw a lot um
yeah girls and women make a lot of
comparisons they spend a lot of time on
social media um and those social
comparisons I already told you lead to
jealousy and that jealousy in turn leads
to externalized or internalized behavior
um I don't think men use social media
the same way we do I really don't um I
don't I don't know how often you take
your screen and zoom it to see um you
know every wrinkle and every hair out of
place do you ever do that I'm just
curious no like do it even like if I ask
my husband he'd be like what are you
even talking about um but certainly we
do that all the time and thank goodness
that feature exists now because I used
to have to take a picture of it and then
I could zoom it um anyhow so uh yeah
it's not good it's not good for the
health of uh of females and and we need
to get a grip on this and figure it out
we did this study that's just under
review and um so one thing I noticed
that happens and hasn't been looked at
but it makes sense so we're really
interested in um threats to
relationships right so like mate
poaching and the like and I know you
know that literature very well um so I
was really interested in female and
friendship poaching and what it looks
like for girls I sorry for women versus
men so what we did was we looked we
developed a scale called a social media
friendship um jealousy scale and
basically said like you know how
affected are you if your friend posts
something and you're not tagged in it or
your friend's geolocator tells you that
they're out with all their friends and
you're not invited um your friend and
it's like just all these things that
happened on social media and we found
that women were more affected than men
by it across three stud
very interesting and then they became
more depressed and anxious as well as a
consequence of that
jealousy wow what's the
underlying Dynamic that social media is
playing on which is
particularly uh effective
at impacting girls mental health like
what what is it the ostracization is it
being felt like feeling like they're
being left out it's that it's that Fe
it's that fomo it's that fear of missing
out it really is significant for girls
and women and it comes back again to
that need to belong I'm not suggesting
that you're all Psychopaths that men are
psychopaths and they don't need uh
positive relationships and affiliation
on the like you certainly do but we need
it more we absolutely do need it more
and so um you know we our value is is
not that it should be but we place a lot
of value on having friends and belonging
um and being included and when we're not
it hurts give me the evolutionary
explanation for why that's the case is
it just that a woman on her own is
fragile and potentially dead is dead
she's so fragile she needs the resources
of other women um you know that's that
tailor tend and befriend hypothesis that
we really do need and there's tons of
evolutionary Scholars who've written
about this that women have historically
relied on other women to to stay alive
and to keep their their children alive
and it still exists in some places in
the world today so it's like a fine line
again you need to belong um more so than
men um but you also have to compete
within this um nest of belonging and
that's really challenging which is why I
think we're so so good at indirect
aggression we're so sophisticated in how
we use it like you're all pretty crude
when you use it and we're not we're like
block
it's a it's a surgeon scalpel rather
than a big hammer totally it's so funny
how often I'll say to my husband oh my
goodness did you notice what she did and
like he didn't even notice she was in
the room
like how do you get through life like
this but then it's like how do we get
through life where we're like so hyper
sensitive and attune to every perception
of slight have you got any idea this uh
attenuation to what's going on in the
the room is that on a sliding scale
where certain women obviously this is on
average there is a bell curve blah
blah is there a particular personality
trait which really tunes that up is it
conscientiousness is it neuroticism is
it you know is there something that you
have found that can quite accurately
predict the level of attenuation that a
girl would have to her surroundings and
the status in her group I think it it
it's not going to be any of the big five
or if you look at the hexaco it's not
going to be any of those per se when we
looked at it we found like
conscientiousness was actually
negatively related to it um but it's
going to be hyperco competitiveness so
there's the competitiveness where you um
just like personal development
competitiveness that you use to better
yourself Vis A yourself and then there's
the I need to be better than everybody
else where like everything is a zero sum
game so women who are hyper competitive
are the ones that are more likely to be
attuned to these things they're more
likely to perceive slight when things
are ambiguous they're more likely to
cause harm to others who they perceive
to have harmed them um to hold grudges
to get others mad at them to so to use
indirect aggression so hyper competitive
women are um they're difficult in a lot
of ways and they're not happy themselves
which is really interesting their mental
health profiles are very problematic wow
talk to me about the relationship
between bullying and social status I had
Tony vul on the show a few months ago I
adored his work on bullying I spent a
lot of time being uh becoming more
familiar with bullying than I would have
liked while I was in school so I was
getting to learn an awful lot what what
have you found about this we've spoken a
lot about social status so far mostly
for for girls but also for boys what is
this how do these two things live in in
relationship to each other so Tony's a
really good friend of mine
um he's fantastic and uh so I I told you
about that study the um shaming
study the sexy confederate study so I
think one of my other more famous
studies if you could say that without
getting knocked down because I'm like
bragging about myself um is um basically
I my for my dissertation my PhD I looked
at Mean Girls the phenomenon before it
even came out as a movie so I was really
interested at the time scientists kept
talking about popular kids being really
well adjusted good citizens in their
schools and that sort of thing and I
kept thinking I'd go to these
conferences and say like what the heck
are you talking about that's not what
popular kids are like but I honestly
think that there's probably an over
representation of nerds in Academia who
weren't in the popular group so they
really didn't know what it was about but
I was in that popular group and we
weren't all that nice in a lot of ways
so I for my dissertation looked at um
adolescence from grade six to grade 12
um and whether or not they had assets
and competencies that the peer group
valued so if they were attractive good
athletes Rich funny tough all of those
things and how that related to bullying
and um other status indicators like
popularity and power and what we found
was or what I found for my dissertation
was that um most kids who bully others
have a lot of power um then then there's
this other group of kids who bully
others who have low power those are like
the Nelsons from The Simpsons right so
um that group kind of indiscriminately
bullies everybody but they're very
marginalized they're rejected um you
know their future is pretty bleak um but
most kids who bully others are actually
the elite of the school so the reason
that they're afforded power and they
abuse their power is because they have
things that the peer group values right
so for girls it's being a attractive and
for boys it's typically being athletic
in North American culture or probably
even in Western culture so every school
is going to have a different culture um
you know you could go to a performing
arts school and the most popular kids at
that school will be maybe the best I
don't know whatever guitar players or
whatever so all this to say whatever the
peer group values that affords you power
that power then in turn typically gets
um corrup Ed and that's true of almost
every human being on the planet power
corrupts and it um and it and absolutely
corrupts right so um so anyhow so that's
what my dissertation was about and it's
been robustly uh uh replicated you know
this is something we see over and over
again I went to Finland early in my
career to give a talk on this and they I
was hosted by uh Christina sov valy and
she's like I don't know if we'll find
this in in land and I was like oh I've
been to your malls you're going to find
it and they found it it's been found
everywhere right so and it exists in
colleges too universities so my daughter
plays D1 soccer it exists in D1 Sports
it exist and sororities that exists in
university
life and then we get out of it what of
two questions first off what do the
bullies get out of it what what is the
benefit to them and secondly why do we
then get out of it what is it about
growing up they get resources right so
we've shown and we've shown with Tony so
Tony and and I have published a few
studies on this they get more sex which
is awesome I guess and good stuff for
for people um they get um uh better
recognition they can influence the peer
group and the Norms of a school more uh
they get more resources people give them
people look at them people adore ad
them all of those things are good right
like they're the Silverbacks of their
school um and then Nobody messes with
them which is also a good feeling I I
don't understand I don't understand how
uh standing on the shoulders of lower
status individuals gives the bully it
bestows that benefit on them that's not
who they bully that group doesn't bully
the the lowest lower standard so they do
a little bit but no it's not that unfair
fight so much so um Bob faris's work and
others have shown that um High status
bullies tend to bully those that are
just at the next rung the ones that are
challenging their status right so those
are the ones that are in
trouble and um or anybody who threatens
their cat bird seat in a sense is that
because it's a signal of low status to
seem like you're in competition with
someone who's supposedly 10 run below
you well they're not on your radar
because you know the thing is the
corrupting influence of power also makes
you impervious to the plight of others
so you're not paying attention to others
unless you're paying attention to people
that are a threat to you that's all
you're really paying attention to so I
don't know if it's that um they're that
conscientious where it's like such an
unfair fight and you're a loser if you
pick on somebody who's perceived as a
loser kind of thing I don't think it's
like that I think it's about maintaining
um so achieving and maintaining hemony I
really think it's about trying to
maintain power and uh and you maintain
power by making sure those that are
trying to threaten your power base don't
get too close there's a meme that very
well may be in your book as well that
says uh everything After High School is
just High School uh where it talks about
you know the lunch table that you sit at
and the cool kids and the games and so
on and so forth you've suggested there
that once your D1 soccer career is over
you enter the real world and these
Dynamics at least begin to dissipate
what how much do they fall away what's
adult bullying look like is there even
such a thing in the same context as
childhood bullying adult bullying looks
different from childhood bullying in
that it's not as um status oriented like
I just suggested these high status
bullies it's more um I mean certainly it
it exists like in the workplace people
will pick on somebody who they perceive
as a threat to them the reason it
dissipates is because our peer groups
are more fluid um they're not as stable
so I think the stability of high school
peer groups is what contributes to it as
well because the hierarchy gets formed
through stability and that doesn't exist
in adulthood as much right so like you
have your hockey friends and then you
have you know your Jim Bros and then you
have I'm just making all of them are Jim
Bros they're all Jim Bros I only have
one group of friends and the all but but
my point is like you know and then you
have the workplace and you have an
atypical job so let's just say like
mostly we go to the job same job where
we see the same people over and over
again all of those things sort of happen
but we have all these different groups
right so it's less likely to take hold
unless there's more stability one place
that does happen though that you kind of
re you kind of um see High School happen
over and over again is when your kids um
when you have kids and then you become
like a soccer mom soccer moms are scary
like there that's where the high school
hierarchy comes up again it's honestly
it's high school all over again there's
a queen be mom she usually is the
manager of the soccer team she organizes
everything in favor of her daughter or
her son um she manipulates other moms uh
you get you don't get included to go to
the mall with them during tournaments
and you know it's all high school all
over again and it's really interesting
why that happens so we kind of relive it
again through our kids right so when the
social groups aren't sufficiently aifi
and stable you don't have enough time
for everything to lock in and for people
to understand I am this with this group
and this with another group School
creates a purpose-built en almost a
purpose-built environment to precisely
create this um predictability of what's
going to go on we know where people have
come before someone come in but they
come into an existing dynamic as opposed
to just being part of this sort of
swirling mess 100% so very well
summarized I think I'm more wordy than
you are but that's probably why you're
good at your job and I'm just like
trying my best here but the other thing
that happens that I think contributes to
this is that we can get out of toxic
relationships a lot easier than kids can
so if I'm in grade 11 and all the girls
are treating me poorly because I'm like
the cute one on campus that sort of
thing like how am I going to to manage
that so I have to change schools and
historically that wasn't really allowed
now we allow it more um before the
internet um you could kind of Escape
that now you can't escape it as much as
you as you used to be able to but anyhow
as adults like okay so the moms are
being mean to me on the soccer
team we just move teams like it's it's
easier than what it is in high school
yeah so again it's that sort of aifi
nature the fact that it's predictable
the fact that it's going to continue
going into the future yeah so funny that
uh you get school and then you leave and
then you get dragged back into school
from your children and then the Dynamics
of school happen again even though
you're no longer in school and yeah and
and they do and they don't like so in
some ways like like I see it replicate
itself also in Academia like Academia oh
man they're a bunch of
like Bully BRS like
but it's like we're like you know when
what's that what's that um what's the
saying you know like when the stakes are
so low you have to fight fiercely and
that's kind of what's happening but
anyhow anytime you can get a hierarchy
going that hierarchy is going to
organize in such a way and the people at
the top are typically going to abuse
their power with very few exceptions so
there are very few people who are just
pure implicit power and implicit power
is the kind of power that you get by
having assets and competency that the
peer View group values and you um you
elevate people you treat them well most
people are a mixture of nice and mean
implicit and explicit power explicit
power is the kind of power you get by uh
you know making people afraid um elting
compliance that sort of thing there was
this my favorite study that's ever been
done was a study on parking and um so
what's your prediction if somebody is in
the parking stall and they know you're
at Costco do you have Costco where you
live you must have Costco yeah I do I
also know I also know the study so if
you try to get me to predict it you can
you can yeah yeah ruin the game so like
the thing is is that when somebody's
waiting for your parking spot you take
longer than when somebody's not work
waiting for your parking spot that's
when you got to do all your safety
checks got to reapply your lip gloss
make sure everything's good gotta answer
that really urgent text and then it's
like oh you want this you're going to
have to wait like that is the ultimate
example of the corrupting influence of
power so people in the right context
tend to abuse their power what is the
impact of bullying on a developing brain
oh my goodness it's enormous and it
persists across the lifespan so we've
done I'd say like most of my research
has been on the neurobiology of peer
victimization so how does it get under
the skin to confer a risk for future
mental health difficulties and health
difficulties so bullying affects all
aspects of functioning not only in
childhood and Adolescence but also in
adulthood so it always hurts so um so
you're going to have the mental health
difficulties the physical health
difficulties the memory issues and the
like but um it impacts your hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal axis which is your
stress response system so at the
beginning you get overly activated um
HPA access because you're stressed out
and then eventually the body adapts and
then you have lower cortisol your HPA
AIS downgrades and that in turn then
causes an inflammation response and then
it affects your cortisol H sorry your
testosterone levels um it has a an
effect on your brain in terms of uh um
places in your brain like areas that are
really rich in gluc cortico receptor
sites so those are the areas of your
brain like your prefrontal cortex and
your hippocampus that are really
sensitive to the effect of cortisol all
so it affects your memory so people
think that kids don't do well at school
because they're bullied um and that's
just because they don't want to go to
school they're not paying attention but
it actually affects their memory I've
shown that in a study that was published
in
2011 um it um has epigenetic processes
too so um you know it you can't change
the gene code but you can certainly
change the expression of genes and uh
you see tiir erosion that you have
shorter tiir which which is an indicator
of um basically if you're going to do
well like in terms of health or die kind
of thing so it's like a good I guess
bioindicator of how much shit's gone
down in your life in a sense yes so it's
terrible this is it's so bad for your
health it's so bad for your brain it's
so bad for everything in your body why
would it be the case that our bodies
would respond to Childhood bully in by
making all of this stuff happen is this
an Adaptive response or is it just a
byproduct of some other I think
it's an Adaptive response which sounds a
bit weird because again back to this
need to belong so if we were all lone
wolves and we weren't like taking care
of each other and we didn't have this
strong need for affiliation we wouldn't
be where we are as humans right um in
every system like so when you look at
the the prevalence of psychopathy is 2%
worldwide you know we can't tolerate
more than 2% on on that on psychopathy
it just creates Havoc so we need to get
along we need to belong um and we need
to feel pretty shitty when we don't
belong because then it motivates you to
then do everything you can to belong um
and then there'd probably be some that
would argue that it also weeds out the
weak but you know the kids people who
get bullied aren't often weak like
people are bullied for variety reasons
and a lot of times especially for
adolescent girls it's because they have
they're pretty they're pretty
good-looking and they have a lot of
assets and competencies like You'
mentioned that you had a pretty rough go
at this what do you think what would you
attribute it to um I struggled to relate
to other kids so I wasn't socially very
attuned or Adept I think I was quite
awkward uh there was definitely a
neediness around I was an only child
going to school I spoke differently I
don't have the accent from the place
that I'm from uh I did Cricket which was
you know seen as this sort of upper
class sport in one of the most
workingclass towns in all of the UK and
yeah it was just ostracized and uh a
combination of not being socially Nimble
and doing things that made you stand out
with probably being a a a physically
unformidable child I was a like a skinny
kid yeah yeah small skinny kid um and I
mean ended up growing
probably height-wise at the same rate as
everybody else but there was lots you
these dudes in school that just hit
puberty at 10 and 10 and a half years
old before you've even got into
Secondary School these guys are massive
so yeah I think that was that would have
contributed a good bit so it's
interesting so we did a study and we
found that like late developing boys
were 22 times more likely to be bullied
than on time their ontime peers so these
like squirty little boys especially in
places that have a dog eat dog world
like the UK and Canada and United States
they don't Fair too well and then they
then they go through puberty and then
life gets a little bit better and it's
interesting though what do you think for
girls so it comes back all full Circles
of shaming wow okay so early
developing girls if you have precocious
puberty and you look more like a woman
early on you're going to be seen as more
of a threat by the girls and they're
going to be picked on Wow because you're
are going to get the attention of the
boys in class they're going to be
looking at the girl who's got boobs at
at 12 years old and the girl that
doesn't have boobs at 12 years old is
going to be ignored the only way that
she can rebalance this disparity is to
claw down the one that's developed you
got it so you can come do your
PhD with me now I'm ready ready to go I
told you I'm I'm moving to Canada uh but
yeah I mean
that the brain developing
thing just to kind of round that out is
the suggest question
that if you was a child ancestrally grew
up in an environment where there was a
lot of uh peer group
ostracization uh an awful lot of
pressure perhaps you were left out
perhaps it was by Design or perhaps it
was simply just as a byproduct of the
climate or the period that you were
living
through there is a likelihood down the
line from that that the world is still
quite an unsafe place to be therefore
you being more forthcoming you being
more needy you being more anxious and
more attached to the people that are
around you is going to be adaptive
because I am living in a period that is
not particularly safe socially or from a
kinship perspective is that kind of the
sort of the narrative story that uh uh
Evolution's telling us I think it's one
pathway and that's the whole thing I
think we tend to want to tell a simple
story but in truth there's tons of het
heterogeneity and we should expect it
like we I mean there's just you know
there's people that start in the same
spot and end up in different spots and
people who end up in this at the end
spots the same but their Beginnings are
so different so multifinality
equifinality that sort of thing I think
that um it's really hard when you think
about the evolutionary significance of
bullying and I know you spoke to to Dr
vul to Tony about this because um like
it's such a cruel experience and it's
such a damaging experience that it's
difficult to put an evolutionary lens on
it and say how could this be adaptive
like I mean I think it's adaptive for
the people who are perpetrating the
violence but not for those that are
receiving the violence I can't think of
how it makes them better people in any
way um people will say that they
wouldn't want to trade their experience
because they've achieved excellence and
it made who they are it's so interesting
how often you hear about people being
bullied and their really prominent
individuals I just watched the Netflix
series uh Beckham have you watched it
yet I haven't no and both um they were
both you know kids isolated kids in a
lot of ways and um and it's interesting
because then I hear this often by people
who have achieved a lot and they said
they were bullied and they think they're
tough because of that that experience is
what made them and I always think okay
so if you're at a on a scale of 1 to 10
and you're at an eight on excellence and
Excellence is like world class
Excellence what if you were supposed to
be a 10 like you know we don't know what
your top was supposed to be maybe you
were supposed to cure cancer well I said
this to I said this to David Goggins who
had opened up an awful lot about the way
that he was treated as a kid both at
school and by his father he had this
tyranical father that was very abusive
and I opened up about for the first time
at the start of this year properly about
sort of bullying in school I hadn't
brought it up before because it just
seemed kind of lame to bring up the fact
that I guess I was still ashamed and
kind of guilty the fact that I had been
mistreated as a kid and like you know
what does it mean to be someone in the
30s still talking about this but then
it's an important part of the origin
story of view and it's been very
formative so you should bring it up but
then it's kind of seems like maybe
you're giving power back to the so there
you know the pingpong game of why you
should or shouldn't bring something up
was kind of strong and one of the things
that I said was something along the
lines of a lot of the things that you're
most proud of in yourself are the light
side of something that you're probably
pretty embarrassed about right yeah and
it's exactly the classic narrative that
you talk about this Alchemy I have taken
something which should have been awful
and I turned it on its head I got to I
took control right I used my agency and
my sovereignty to kind of wrangle this
reality into something which is good to
me now there's I I'm falling in love
with this Frame at the moment things
which are literally true but
figuratively false and things that are
figuratively false but literally true um
I think that I think that this is one of
those things that may be literally true
but figuratively false or or at least
functionally false which
is I may have been a much better
businessman son and podcaster had I've
not been
bullied but belief in that is completely
pointless and the only way that I can
amarate the fact that I did get
mistreated in school is for me to say
actually
most of the things that I went through
helped to not only not hold me back but
also Forge me into the situation that
I'm in because believing about the other
Universe the second strand where you
weren't and thinking about just how much
further ahead you could have got is just
a recipe for victimhood and misery and
it's uh yeah literally true functionally
false perhaps you know it's interesting
too it kind of highlights back to that
heterogeneity point that I was making so
like I do think that some individuals
are bullied and they do okay they Faire
better and um and the reason why one
person goes left and one person goes
right is is varied like you know the
attributions that you're making are
really important and there's those are
helpful but there's also biological risk
that we never talked about so for
example and this has kind of been this
is a bit dated but it gives you it's a
really simple way of explaining it so
I'll use it but just know that the
genetics have caught up and that things
are a little bit B more complicated than
this um so um caspy Moffet and all um
published a seminal paper in science in
19 or sorry 2003 and uh basically they
looked at 5htt L so it's the serotonin
transporter Dre Gene the polymorphism of
it so you can get you get 50% of your
genes from your mom 50% from your dad so
you can have a long Al um like a long
long Al a short short Al and a short
long Al and
having um the short Al is a risk factor
for depression because it it it's
implicated in how serotonin is used by
your body so anyhow they looked at kids
who were um maltreated in childhood and
the likelihood of them becoming
depressed at age
26 and whether or not it was moderated
by their 5 HDT LPR and what they found
was that if you were bullied or sorry
Mal treated treated in childhood and you
had the short shorter Le you were 65%
you had a 65% chance of being depressed
in adulthood if you had the same
horrible experience and you had the
protective long long then you were no
more likely to be depressed than if you
hadn't been abused so do you know what
your 5hd LPR polymorphism is no but I
can ask someone because I've had a full
I've had a full Gene scan done so this
is my point like you don't like okay so
now we know you could you 23 and me we
can have some idea but it really is
important for people to understand this
because sometimes too when people aren't
resilient we blame them again so they
get bullied and then they're not
resilient on their on being bullied and
we say ah you see you know look at
should have tried harder should have
done the one yeah like Chris came out of
it and he's a better he's a better
person he's done all of these things you
know um so if you could just you know be
stronger
you don't know what their biological
risk is I mean this is the it's
ultimately the brutal red pill of
behavioral genetics right that the raw
materials that everybody is starting
with is not the same and when you fold
when you fold that in with epigenetics
and determinism you have a a a pretty
brutal soup for quite a nihilistic life
you know if you don't believe that
there's free will and if you believe
that the predisposition that you had was
ordained before you were even born and
then if you learned that epigene I
thought epigenetics was total
and then I had sapolsky on and he he
totally blew my mind and there are
things that can have happened to your
parents' lives that aren't a part of
their genetics which can influence the
genetics that they will give to you the
behavior that your mother goes through
when you're in utero will have huge
changes epigenetic changes that are
locked in for the rest of the life and
not only that it's now your kids and
your grandkids are potenti because your
your grandmother made the ovam that
became you right I mean exactly so these
stressors play out into generations to
come my point in telling this is just
it's really important because like so
there's like you know talking about
genetic risk but there's also
attribution risks so for example Studies
have shown that we're really keen on
reducing bullying and uh but Studies
have shown that when you're the only kid
in the class being bullied your mental
health outcomes are worse than if
there's multiple kids being bullied in
the classroom so then how do we
reconcile that and it makes sense
because if I'm the only one being
bullied then it's something I've done
right but if everybody's getting bullied
it's because there's some in our
classroom that's just picking on
everybody so there's there's like a
communism of bullying solution here you
know there's like misery loves company
so so here we're trying to reduce
bullying and then we're we're having
this issue the other thing that's really
interesting about the intervention
literature and I'm given actually a talk
to um the Montreal School Board tomorrow
on this is that um studies has shown so
back to Christina Salma Valley I told
you I went to Finland and I told them
that you know I went to your mall I know
you're going to have popular bullies
that have a lot of assets and
competencies what they found they have
like almost every kid in the country
involved in their studies and they have
this big anti-bullying program called
the Kaa um they found that the ones that
were most impervious to their
anti-bullying um efforts were the
highest status bullies
why would you give up your your power
holding
position so yeah what what about so for
the people that are listening who might
be thinking okay well I went through
some bad times in school uh am I now
locked into a life of suboptimal brain
development and my hippocampus and gry
matters smaller I'm never going to be
able to remember my 16 digit number
across the front of my card how possible
is it to reverse the harm that's being
created neurologically
biologically from bullying so we don't
know but I think that it's going to be
okay for a lot of people and the reason
I say that is that we're adaptive like
so we have hundreds of thousands of
years of selection pressure we are
designed to survive we're designed to be
resilient and so um we know that
neuroplasticity exists across the
lifespan so we you know we can I think
reverse some of this damage for sure but
in the absence of knowing that knowing
that it causes us much harm it behooves
us to be better citizens and we we
really need to be reducing this right we
can't just be hoping that well you know
in the end at the end of the day we'll
be able to fix this in your late 30s or
something yeah I well and also the the
just the lived experience I again like I
can fly the flag from my ethnographic
research like it's just not enjoyable
like have this 4,000 weeks that you've
got on this planet and of them however
many hundred is spent like really just
not enjoying your time feeling bad about
yourself it's funny that you said that
like I'm giving um the keynote for
unicef's violence um conference that's
coming up Pro violence presumably Pardon
Me pro violence presumably yeah yeah
you're Pro you're Pro you're going
into violence Symposium yeah exactly
yeah anti you mean antiviolence anyhow
um and so the abstruct that I wrote was
just about what you said in a sense like
that um it's interesting how people with
live experience have told us over and
over again how harmful this was and is
being bullied being treated poorly um
even women being treated poorly by other
women and um and yet we needed to like
put 30 years worth of science to it to
in a sense acknowledge their pain was
real like how like that's like
we like why did we need to do this like
we certainly needed to show it but why
do we have to show it over and over
again like we keep showing it without
doing anything about it like we need to
do something about it and
stop documenting the harms well
definitely you know speaking as a a
member a proud member of the ex bolied
Community I guess one of the issues with
at least being two forthcoming is what I
said at the beginning it's the reason I
was reticent to bring it up in the first
place on the show that it's a signal of
low status you know you'd already had to
battle with this before in the past is
this not something that I should have
already got passed into adulthood is
this really something that plays on my
mind and even if it's something that
doesn't play on your mind and that you
have got past and you do feel like
you've managed to get a balanced life
and you've got friends that you care
about and you think that you've repaired
the damage that might have been done to
your brain and all the rest of the
stuff even the fact that you're able to
acknowledge that it was a part of the
story in the first place is also kind of
still this signal vulnerability you
don't want to give the people that
mistreated you any more power any more
time or any more thought than they
already got out of you when it was
happening at the time so it's just a you
know the real Litany of reasons as to
why people who have gone through
bullying wouldn't want to bring it up
even in adulthood when it's no longer
affecting them it's interesting because
um women are more uh vengeful than men
you may not think that but it's true um
so we never forget somebody who's done
us wrong remember I said said so if I
was you and I had the podcast like
meaning like I was as popular as you and
I had the good lighting that you have in
the back of me and stuff like that I'd
be naming
names i' be like here's the list of the
people who with
me I'd doubt them but you're like a
Kinder person it's interesting that you
still say this though because um you're
probably very familiar with the social
pain research no what's that okay so
there so um about a maybe about 15 years
ago um you know with the the
advancements and fmis and the like what
they found was that the physical pain
Network so you stub your toe your brain
lights up it tells you you know this
thing just happened you pull your foot
away that sort of thing so there's this
mechanism and we know what parts of the
brain that are um activated when you
physically hurt yourself when you're
ostracized treated poorly bullied you
name it the same areas of your brain are
activated it's called social pain the
difference between social pain and
physical pain so there's overlapping
neuro structures physical and and social
pain and this has evolutionary
significance again because um it's a
neural alarm that you're not belonging
so you better be motivated to get back
in there and belong right so it actually
does hurt and it's interesting because
like when you think about the physical
pain met or the the the physical pain
metaphors are used to describe social
pain around the world broke my heart
when I wasn't invited to that party I
felt like he punched me in the stomach
when I think about it right so the thing
about physical pain is that it's
short-lived so I had two daughters and
both times the epidural didn't take
which is complete BS but I can tell you
and I don't have a visceral reaction I
don't but if I think about the time when
my daughter was in grade six and she
wasn't invited to that party I feel like
I felt that day and so social pain lasts
a lifetime and it's very it's it's very
um socially motivating but it's really
hard to shake so when you're 88 and you
think about when you were eight you'll
feel the same thing it's so Salient and
that's been shown to be very robust um
so you know this is why it hurts it
hurts forever um it's it serves an
evolutionary um function but it's kind
of like an evolutionary function that
took steroids and and kind of went off
have you looked at interventions for
people to grow beyond the vestage of the
bullying no but I mean I would say that
probably the better programs would be
cognitive behavioral therapy I think
that that would be the way to deal with
it because it's really about reframing
that and and being kind to yourself like
kind of the things that you've been
saying you know that makes sense to me
and it the reframing is really important
um you know there's kids who get bullied
like where the peer group says they're
being bullied and they say they're not
bullied and their mental health profile
looks good and then there's kids who say
they're um they're being bullied and the
peer group doesn't say they're being
bullied and their mental health profiles
look bad because at the end of the day
it's how you perceive Environ that
matters right yeah yeah very interesting
your per of the event given that you're
talking about this an awful lot it's
obviously a topic that you're passionate
about what are the interventions that
look most promising for reducing the
rates of bullying so the most programs
don't work very well they work a tiny
bit if they work at all and then there
was a a paper that just came out of
metaanalysis that involved over a
hundred studies and it showed that the
effects were pretty small again um
better than they've been in the past but
the programs that work tend to be
Universal so they address all kids in
the school um they do it before they
head out of middle school because
they're not very effective in high
school um they um involve the peers but
are not
peer-led um they um include education of
teachers um they have consistency so
there's like some components here and
there but ultimately I think that the
reason the programs don't work is
because we don't have a good enough
appreciation of that
that dichotomy I talked about the low
status bullies and the high status
bullies and I think historically all of
our programs have been devoted towards
um the remediation of Nelson instead of
the remediation of you know that mean
girl cck I think then we'd be in a
better position if we um if we address
that that top tier group it's such a
uh kind of like not a game of Russian
Roulette but a little bit of a catch 20
too for parents and for the kid you know
by bringing it up there's a fear that
more bullying is going to happen to you
the parent goes into school that also
lowers the status of the kid presumably
because they can't handle it on their
own and then the parent now is super
Vigilant I mean there must be something
like uh even though it's no longer a
developing brain but a second order
parent to the child that's being bullied
vigilance effect which is going on you
know increased anxiety all the rest of
it so they're now going to be asking
their kid when they come home did that
girl speak to you today has anything
changed and you're then kind of scared
cuz Mom I don't want to say if I tell
you what's happened then you're I'm
scared you're going to shout at me I
feel like I'm at fault and you end up as
the child I certainly did this with my
parents I ended up being like being
scared of telling my mom and dad that
bad things had happened at school
but I was also having to absorb the bad
things that were happening so you end up
kind of like I don't know this sort of
neutron star that's just absorbing
whatever whatever is around it a
desperate attempt to try and just not
make the situation any worse so I need
everybody to understand that most
studies show that when you tell somebody
you're being bullied like a caring adult
in your school that bullying stops and
it tends to stop immediately so we have
this misperception that it's not going
to be dealt with if we actually say
something out loud so a lot of times
what happens is kids um finally tell
somebody six months after the fact when
it's been going on for far too long and
now they're like they're near death
store kind of thing so that's really
important that people understand they
should be telling somebody but
oftentimes parents advocacy is I
understand why it happens but it's maybe
not the best advocacy to your point and
it's because it's m neuron system
systems right so they're absolutely
feeling what their kid is feeling and
they have an intolerance for their
kids's discomfort and they want it
addressed immediately so they come in
and they're probably not in a good
position to advocate for their kid
because they're too emotionally charged
instead of coming in and rationally
speaking about this it's hard to be
rational when your baby's hurting I get
that but if you did you'd get a little
bit further I think with the schools um
the schools most schools in the world
have to deal with this even at a legal
point so like for example in Ontario
where I live it's in our education act
that they have to address bullying so
they're motivated legally if not morally
and they are morally motivated but if
even if they weren't they would be
legally motivated to do something so
that's that's how it's done now when you
were being bullied that wasn't the case
like it was really like the Wild Wild
West in a lot of ways right and like
teachers even bullied kids and it was
about like it sorted itself out and
that's just how it is you know it was
darwinian thinking on this which was
problematic so yeah it's tough kid
parents need to advocate for their kids
they need to do it rationally kids need
to understand that their parents aren't
going to screw it up if they go in calm
and that the school will deal with it
it's not going to fix everything
overnight but it certainly will fix a
lot of things all right Tracy let's
bring this one home I want run this back
again next year when your book comes out
but for the people that have loved what
they've heard today where should they go
if they want to keep up to date with all
your work so um I'm on this platform
called Twitter X where you go to get
bullied um
so so you can keep up with it with me
there um it's really lovely I just just
love my interactions there um I think
that's probably the best place because
I'm not on any other social media Med
site so um got to keep my social
comparisons low so I my mental health is
good very nice Tracy I really appreciate
you thank you it was so nice chatting
with you Chris I could do it all day
long if you enjoyed that episode then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
weeks and don't forget to
subscribe